This video’s sponsored by Audible.
To get a free audiobook, like Game of Thrones
or Dune or Wheel of Time, sign up for a trial
at the link below.
Game of Thrones author George Martin said
that he likes Tyrion Lannister.
Tyrion is “the villain” of course – but
there’s nothing like a good villain.
The first few seasons of the Thrones TV show
are a.. pretty close adaptation of the books
– Tyrion is a smart, funny dwarf who uses
his wits in politics, but feels rejected and
unloved.
When he’s condemned for a crime that he
didn’t commit, he kills his father Tywin
and his lover Shae.
But after Season 4, Tyrion in the show becomes
a totally different character to Tyrion in
the books.
In the show, Tyrion joins Daenerys cause he
believes she will make the world better.
He tries to help her take the Throne without
killing innocent people, and without killing
his siblings Cersei and Jaime.
But Tyrion’s plans all fail.
His peace in Meereen fails, his war plans
fail, his Cersei deal fails [including his
ludicrous wight hunt idea], and his plan
for King’s Landing fails when Daenerys burns
the city.
Tyrion used to be a smart and ruthless political
player, but he spends most of the last two
seasons just standing around looking sad and
helpless.
In the finale he tells Jon to kill Dany, and
he says Bran should be king, and everything’s
sort of okay in the end.
Tyrion’s story was about his use of political
power, and his need for love and family.
But the ending of the show doesn’t resolve
these themes.
He fails politically but.. still gets power.
And his family dies and no one loves him,
but he’s.. just kind of okay still.
He doesn’t change or grow as a character,
and he barely impacts the story apart from
the thirty minutes.
The final line of dialogue in Game of Thrones
is Tyrion telling a joke, but we don’t hear
the punchline.
Which is a good metaphor for Tyrion’s story
in the show – there’s a great set-up in
the first few seasons, but there’s no punchline,
no emotional payoff in the end.
Because Tyrion in the show is not the real
Tyrion Lannister.
In the books, his story is very different,
and much darker.
After killing Tywin and
Shae, Tyrion is traumatised,
and angry.
He doesn’t want to protect Cersei and Jaime,
he wants to kill his siblings, for revenge.
And he doesn’t want to protect innocent
people – he wants to bring “fire and sword”
to Westeros.
He thinks of himself as a “vengeful ghost”
coming to “haunt the Seven Kingdoms” – “They
would not love me living, so let them dread
me dead”.
So what is Tyrion’s story in the books,
and.. is Tyrion Lannister a villain?
Tyrion in the books looks very different to
Peter Dinklage in the show.
Book-Tyrion is ugly – he has a “brutish”
“squashed-in face”, he’s described as
“grotesque” “like a gargoyle”.
His hair is pale blond, and his eyes are two
different colours – one green and one black.
When Tyrion is wounded in battle, he doesn’t
just get a cool scar – half his nose is
cut off, leaving his face hideously “disfigured”.
Tyrion’s ugliness is important because it’s
part of why people reject him and see him
as a monster.
One of the inspirations behind Tyrion’s
character is Richard the Third, who was a
King of England in the Wars of the Roses.
In histories and literature, Richard was portrayed
as a devious villain who killed his family
to gain power.
And supposedly, Richard was ugly and deformed
with a hunchback – his evil soul was reflected
in an ugly twisted body.
Modern historians doubt whether any of that
was actually true about Richard.
But the point is that because of Tyrion’s
ugly appearance, people
are prejudiced against him.
Tyrion was rejected from the day he was born.
Tyrion’s father Tywin was always proud and
ambitious.
But Tywin’s father Lord Tytos was weak – his
lords mocked and laughed at him to his face.
Young Tywin hated the humiliation and shame
that this brought to their noble family.
So Tywin fought “to restore the pride and
power” of House Lannister, brutally exterminating
whole families who rebelled against them.
Tywin became Lord of Casterly Rock, and Hand
of the King for Aerys Targaryen.
Tywin married his cousin Joanna, and he loved
her deeply – it’s said that only she saw
the real Tywin beneath his cold harsh armour.
They had twins, Cersei and Jaime – Tywin
wanted Cersei to be queen, and Jaime a great
knight – he dreamed they’d be “so strong
and brave and beautiful that no one would
ever laugh at them”.
After the humiliation of his father Tytos,
laughter was what Tywin hated most.
But then, Joanna died giving birth to Tyrion
– an ugly “malformed” dwarf.
In the superstitious society of Westeros,
people thought Tyrion’s birth was a dark
omen foretelling disaster.
King Aerys mocked Tywin, and said Tyrion was
a punishment from the gods – that they took
Tywin’s beautiful wife and gave him a monster
to teach him humility.
The smallfolk called Tyrion “Lord Tywin’s
Doom”.
So Tyrion’s birth hurt the two things Tywin
loved most – it undermined the pride and
dignity of House Lannister, and caused the
death of his beloved wife.
So Tywin always hated Tyrion, and was cold
and cruel to him.
Cersei copied her father and also hated Tyrion.
The only immediate family who showed Tyrion
any affection or respect was his brother Jaime.
Jaime gave him toys, and taught him to ride
a pony, and Tyrion loved and trusted Jaime
more than anyone.
He also liked his uncles Tygett and Gerion.
Gerion taught Tyrion about the wonders of
the world, and taught him acrobatics, like
flips and walking on his hands.
But Tywin hated Tyrion acting a fool, and
being laughed at, so he stopped the acrobatics.
Tywin also refused to let Tyrion travel the
world with Gerion, and instead put him in
charge of the drains and cisterns at Casterly
Rock.
So Tyrion had a lonely childhood, finding
comfort in books about history and dragons.
Rejected by his father and his sister, and
with no mother, Tyrion desperately wanted
to be loved.
When Tyrion was thirteen, he met a common
girl called Tysha.
They fell in love, and got married, happily
living as husband and wife for two weeks.
But when Tywin found out, he was furious that
Tyrion had shamed House Lannister by marrying
an unworthy woman.
Jaime told Tyrion that Tysha was a “whore”
– that Jaime paid Tysha to be with Tyrion,
and that she didn’t really love him.
To teach Tyrion a lesson, Tywin had Tysha
raped by his guards.
Then he made Tyrion rape Tysha.
And the marriage was ended.
So the one time that Tyrion fell in love with
someone, he learned that that love wasn’t
real.
He was betrayed, humiliated, and forced to
violate and dehumanise his wife.
Ever since Tysha, Tyrion believed that no
woman would ever truly love him, that they’d
only want him for his gold.
So Tyrion turns to sex workers and wine.
But Tyrion says that while whores will fuck
you, they won’t kiss you – Tyrion craves
real intimacy, and approval, and a place in
the world.
He’s not a warrior like Jaime.
He doesn’t have power like Tywin.
He’s not feared or loved.
But he is smart.
He’s good at strategy, and manipulating
people.
So Tyrion reads lots of books – he says
his mind is his weapon, and his wits are all
he has.
When Tyrion is about 25 years old, Book 1
begins.
He goes up to Winterfell with King Robert
and the rest, and he makes friends with Jon
Snow.
In the books, Tyrion does an acrobatic jump
and somersault here, which author George Martin
later said he.. “could have left out”
cause it’s.. kinda silly.
But Jon feels rejected from his family for
being a bastard, just like Tyrion feels rejected
for being a dwarf.
So he gives Jon advice – he says when people
make fun of you and call you names, you should
take that name, and make it your armour.
So like when people mock Tyrion and call him
the Imp, Tyrion takes on the persona of a
sarcastic cynical Imp.
He uses jokes and irony as a shield to deflect
the hurt of rejection.
And he uses his sharp tongue to make fun of
people back.
Tyrion slaps Joffrey for being a dick.
He stands up for Jon against the bullying
Alliser Thorne, and defeats him in a mighty
duel with a crab fork.
Tyrion gives Bran a special saddle design,
so he can ride a horse after his injury – Tyrion
has sympathy for cripples, bastards and broken
things, he identifies with outcasts and underdogs.
But Tyrion can also be cruel and vindictive.
Even in small ways.
Like, he dislikes Benjen Stark, so Tyrion
takes Benjen’s warm clothes to make Benjen
cold, just out of petty spite.
When Catelyn captures Tyrion, he plots revenge
on all her men.
He especially hates the singer Marillion for
making fun of him.
So when they’re attacked, Tyrion stomps
on Marillion’s hand, and breaks his fingers
– just cause he’s annoyed by this guy’s
singing!
Lysa falsely accuses Tyrion of murder.
And it’s easy to frame Tyrion, because he’s
an ugly Imp, and people are biased against
him.
But Tyrion escapes using his wits and his
words – he convinces Bronn, and the mountain
clansmen to join him.
Tyrion says he’ll help the mountain clansmen
attack the Vale.
And in the books, he’s serious about this.
He plans “to reduce the Vale of Arryn to
a smoking wasteland”.
He thinks there’s nothing he’d enjoy more
than getting revenge on Lysa, “except perhaps
strangling Cersei”.
He often fantasises about killing Cersei and
Tywin.
Even as a child, he dreamed of burning his
sister and father in dragonfire.
So from the beginning, book--Tyrion has a
dark side that wasn’t in the TV show.
Being mistreated and disrespected makes him
angry, and he wants to pay his debts with
violent revenge.
Tyrion meets with his father Tywin as the
Lannisters go to war with the Starks and Tullys.
And Tywin fights this war in the most violent
and destructive way possible.
He orders his most brutal soldiers like the
Mountain to burn and plunder the riverlands,
killing and raping innocent people.
And Tyrion doesn’t question this.
He’s there when Tywin gives the orders.
He sees villages burned, and sees innocent
people killed by his family.
And Tyrion has no sympathy – because Tyrion
thinks like Tywin.
It was Tywin who taught Tyrion that a Lannister
pays his debts with brutal indiscriminate
violence – “I see you have taken a few
lessons from me” Tywin says.
And that’s why Tyrion wants violent revenge
on Marillion, the Vale, and ironically, on
Tywin.
Tyrion does hate Tywin, but he’s still desperate
for his father’s love and approval, so he’s
internalised Tywin’s brutal methods, and
tries to be like him.
But no matter how hard Tyrion tries, Tywin
just criticises and humiliates Tyrion, saying
he’s weak and useless.
Tywin’s constant negging makes Tyrion feel
insecure, inadequate, and unloved.
Tywin orders Tyrion to fight on the front
lines of a battle, and Tyrion realises that
his father wants to get him killed.
So before the battle, Tyrion feels lonely,
and he meets a girl called Shae, who agrees
to be his lover, in return for gold.
Shae is just eighteen years old in the books.
She’s witty and charming, and when they
have sex, she acts like she enjoys it and
calls him her “giant of Lannister”.
Tyrion knows she’s just pretending to like
him, but he’s so desperate for love that
he wants to believe that it’s real.
In the TV show, Shae eventually does love
Tyrion for real.
But not in the books.
Author George Martin says Shae doesn’t give
a shit about Tyrion, and is only in it for
the money and status.
And Tyrion knows this, but after his experience
with Tysha, he feels that fake love is all
he can get.
At the battle, in the TV show, Tyrion gets
knocked out and misses the whole thing – because
the showrunners didn’t have the budget for
a battle in Season 1.
But in the books, Tyrion rides in and fights
– he kills some blokes, and stabs a horse
with his hat, and he survives this battle.
So [now that Jaime has been captured] Tywin
gives Tyrion a hint of praise and respect
for once.
He tells Tyrion to go to King’s Landing
and rule as Hand of the King.
But Tywin also tells Tyrion not to bring his
“whore” Shae.
The talk of whores brings up Tyrion’s anger
and pain for what Tywin did to Tysha.
So Tyrion defies his father and brings Shae
to King’s Landing.
So in Book 1, Tyrion is hurt and angry at
world that rejects him.
He wants love, and respect, and revenge.
In Book 2, Tyrion takes power in King’s
Landing, and he says he’s going to do “justice”.
He gets rid of the corrupt [gold cloak commander]
Janos Slynt, because Janos’ men killed a
baby and her mother.
Tyrion imprisons and humiliates Pycelle for
disobeying him.
Tyrion blackmails Lancel Lannister, and bribes
the Kettleblacks to spy on Cersei.
He sends Myrcella to marry a Martell, and
makes a plan to free Jaime from the Starks.
Tyrion feels very impressed with himself for
his clever political plots – he thinks he
“can scheme with any man”, that this is
what he was made for.
But he’s not really as successful he thinks.
Like sure, Tyrion outsmarts Janos and Pycelle
and Lancel, but those guys are small fry – the
real dangerous players are Littlefinger and
Varys, and Tyrion never figures out what they’re
up to.
And many of Tyrion’s plots fail.
The Kettleblacks were working for Littlefinger
all along, not Tyrion.
Myrcella’s marriage just lets the Martells
use her against the Lannisters.
Tyrion’s plot to free Jaime fails.
And Tyrion’s insults to Pycelle, and Joffrey
and Cersei and the Kingsguard and others just
create enemies who turn against Tyrion in
the end.
So Tyrion is not as clever as he thinks he
is.
And he doesn’t really do justice.
Like, sure, he gets rid of Janos Slynt, or
just makes him Jon Snow’s problem, but the
person who ordered Janos to kill a baby was
Cersei, and Tyrion feels he can’t bring
her to justice.
Tyrion also realises that his own men, like
Bronn, are just as cutthroat and immoral as
Janos was.
So he admits to himself that he isn’t really
doing justice.
Ultimately, Tyrion works as Hand of the King
for King Joffrey, a cruel incompetent child
tyrant.
Tyrion knows that Joffrey is a terrible king.
And he knows that he isn’t the rightful
king – he’s a bastard of incest, making
Stannis the true king.
Tyrion knows that Cersei and Tywin are cruel
terrible rulers.
And he knows that their army commits evil
atrocities in the riverlands.
A river lord says that Lannister soldiers
are burning, raping and killing innocent people.
And Tyrion doesn’t care, he says that’s
just war.
Which is a bullshit excuse.
The Starks and Tullys and Stannis don’t
wage war like that – the Lannisters are
exceptionally brutal.
In between Tyrion’s chapters, we get chapters
from Arya’s perspective, as she experiences
the horror of Lannister atrocities – making
it really clear that Tyrion is on the wrong
side of this war.
All his clever political plots support a brutal
illegitimate government, fighting against
the heroic Starks and righteous Stannis.
Tyrion also mostly ignores the threat of the
white walker apocalypse, even though the Night’s
Watch repeatedly asks him for help.
Tyrion doesn’t do justice in Book 2.
It’s not about the realm.
It’s about his ego.
After a lifetime of being mocked and disrespected,
Tyrion loves having power and status.
He thinks “me, the dwarf, the monster, the
one they scorned and laughed at”, “now
I hold it all, the power, the city, the girl”,
and “I do love it”.
Tyrion’s humiliation of Lancel and Pycelle
isn’t about political strategy.
It’s about making himself feel powerful,
making himself feel tall.
Tyrion’s feelings of resentment are understandable
and sympathetic.
But he uses his power to bully and humiliate,
to feed his ego, and to fight on the wrong
side of this war.
That’s why Tyrion is “the villain” in
Book 2.
Throughout the book, Tyrion struggles for
power with Cersei.
They’re both on team Lannister.
But they each want the power for themselves.
So they undermine and lie and insult and spy
on each other.
There is one moment when Tyrion and Cersei
celebrate and are happy together, but Tyrion
uses this opportunity to slip Cersei a mild
poison, to get rid of her for a few days.
And the relationship really breaks down when
Tyrion gets between Cersei and her children.
Tyrion sends Myrcella to Dorne.
He takes Tommen away for safekeeping.
And he puts Joffrey in a battle.
Cersei feels that her children are threatened,
so she retaliates by threatening the people
Tyrion loves.
She captures a sex worker called Alayaya,
thinking that she’s Tyrion’s lover Shae.
And she threatens to torture and kill the
girl if Cersei’s children are hurt.
So how does Tyrion react?
He could just tell Cersei the truth – that
she’s got the wrong girl, that Tyrion would
never hurt her children, that they’re on
the same side and shouldn’t fight – but
instead, Tyrion decides to be like Tywin,
and to speak with “his father’s voice”.
Tyrion says if Alayaya is beaten and raped,
Tyrion will beat and rape Tommen.
He promises to hurt Cersei, to turn her joy
to ashes in her mouth.
This is the moment Tyrion and Cersei become
enemies.
And it happens because instead of being honest
decent people, they both act like their brutal
ruthless father.
Their petty sibling rivalry for Tywin’s
love spirals into murder, hate, and eventual
disaster for their family.
Tyrion defends King’s Landing from Stannis.
He blows up Stannis’ ships with wildfire,
and in the books he traps the burning ships
with a giant chain.
We see from Davos’ perspective as Tyrion’s
wildfire kills his sons, and thousands of
others – so from Davos’ perspective, Tyrion
is totally the villain.
Tyrion leads an attack, and fights amidst
fiery ships like a badass.
But then Tyrion’s attacked by one of
his own men – Mandon Moore slashes Tyrion’s
face open – possibly under Cersei’s orders,
or Joffrey’s, or Littlefinger’s.
But Tyrion goes down, and Tywin and the Tyrells
arrive to win the battle.
At the end of the book, Tyrion is badly wounded,
his face is disfigured, and he’s alone.
He has fever dreams and visions of the thousands
of people he killed in battle, burned corpses
weeping and moaning.
He thinks “Why did I kill them all?”
And then he dreams the answer – he dreams
of a feast where everyone praises him as a
hero, Jaime makes him a knight, Shae embraces
him – and his father Tywin smiles with “approval”.
This is why Tyrion fought this war, and played
politics.
It’s because he wants to be loved.
But in Book 3, Tyrion gets no love.
Tywin takes all the credit for winning the
battle, and takes Tyrion’s power as Hand
of the King.
Tyrion’s allies are replaced and scattered,
and Tyrion feels abandoned.
So Tyrion goes to his father and asks for
some “gratitude” and recognition for saving
the city, and bleeding for their family.
He asks to be publicly acknowledged as Tywin’s
son and heir – since Jaime is a Kingsguard,
Tyrion should be the next Lord of Casterly
Rock.
But Tywin refuses.
He calls Tyrion an ill-made “creature”,
“devious”, “spiteful” and full of
lust.
He says he’ll never let Tyrion turn Casterly
Rock into his “whorehouse”.
Tywin is angry that Tyrion threatened Cersei
to protect Alayaya.
So Tywin has Alayaya whipped, and kicked out
the city gates naked.
Tywin brings up Tysha, and Shae, and says
he’ll kill Tyrion’s whores.
So Tywin’s hatred of Tyrion is connected
to Tywin’s feelings about women and sex,
which goes back to Tywin’s relationship
with his own father, Tytos.
Cause after Tywin’s mother died, Tytos took
common women as his mistresses.
One mistress became proud and influential,
ordering people around at the Rock.
And she wore Tywin’s mother’s clothes
and jewellery.
Tywin was furious that a lowborn woman had
power and status in House Lannister, and had
impinged on the memory of his mother.
So when Tytos died, Tywin stripped the woman,
and walked her naked through the streets to
show the world she was a “whore”.
Now, Tywin does the same thing with Alayaya,
and did something similar with Tysha.
So because of his own daddy issues, Tywin
is paranoid and insecure about lower-class
women undermining his pride, so he uses brutal
sexual violence and public humiliation to
put women beneath the dignity of his noble
house.
So Tywin hates that Tyrion openly has sex
with lowborn women like Tytos did.
He hates that Tyrion is mocked and laughed
at, like Tytos was.
Tywin says “I was made to suffer my father’s
follies.
I will not suffer yours”.
Tyrion reminds Tywin of all
his deepest insecurities
about his father and women and his grief for
his wife.
And it’s not fair, or rational, but that’s
why Tywin hates Tyrion, and rejects him so
brutally.
Tyrion knows that Shae is in danger from Tywin,
and it’d be safer to send her away.
But she’s the only person who makes him
feel loved.
Even though he knows she’s just using him
for his money.
Shae is not a nice person in the books.
She says cruel things about Lollys, a disabled
rape victim.
And Tyrion isn’t nice to Shae sometimes.
He slaps her, he isolates and controls her,
he risks the life of this teenage girl for
his gratification.
And then Tyrion gets in
another shitty relationship
with a teenager.
Tywin tells Tyrion to marry Sansa Stark, so
that the Lannisters can use her claim to take
over the north.
And Tyrion has mixed feelings.
He says Sansa is “too young” to marry
– cause she’s just twelve years old in
the books – but Tyrion would like to rule
Winterfell, and get away from his family.
Tyrion offers for Sansa to marry Lancel instead,
but Sansa remembers that Tyrion was kind to
her once, and she hasn’t really got a choice,
so they go along with the wedding.
Sansa refuses to kneel for the wedding cloak
though, so Tyrion has to stand on the back
of a jester.
The wedding is humiliating and depressing
for them both.
Tyrion gets drunk and threatens King Joffrey.
Then they go to bed.
Tywin told Tyrion to have sex with Sansa to
consummate the marriage and secure her claim
on the north.
And at first, Tyrion intends to have sex with
her.
But Sansa doesn’t want him, so he relents,
and they settle into their distant uncomfortable
marriage.
Tyrion tries to connect with her – he’s
so desperate for love and validation, but
she doesn’t want him, cause she’s twelve,
and she’s a political prisoner, and Tyrion’s
family killed her family.
So their marriage is “a daily agony”.
Tywin keeps telling Tyrion to have sex with
Sansa, and Tyrion’s angry that his father
keeps trying to control his sex life.
A singer blackmails Tyrion, so Tyrion has
him killed and made into soup.
Tyrion’s stressed – he has a shitty job
as master of coin, there’re Martells and
Tyrells to deal with.
His child wife hates him, his dad wants to
kill his girlfriend, the queen hates him,
the king hates him, the common people hate
him and think he’s “a twisted little monkey
demon”.
House Lannister is more powerful than ever,
but Tyrion feels miserable and alone.
At Joffrey’s wedding, there’s a performance
by some dwarfs, who ride a dog and a pig and
joust for entertainment.
Joffrey tells Tyrion to ride the pig, and
Tyrion refuses, so they get angry and insult
each other publicly.
Then Joffrey dies of poisoned wine, and Cersei
accuses Tyrion of the murder.
At the trial, Tyrion has no friends to defend
him – Bronn gets bribed by Cersei, and Podrick
is just a boy.
What Tyrion does have is a lot of enemies.
All the people Tyrion threatened and humiliated
over the last two books come back to condemn
him.
And they make a strong case that Tyrion poisoned
Joffrey, because Tyrion did steal poison,
and he did threaten Joffrey – he publicly
swore to geld Joffrey.
Of course, Tyrion didn’t really intend to
cut off his nephew’s penis.
Just like he didn’t really want to hurt
Tommen.
He only made these threats because he was
angry and hurt, and cause he thought that
acting like Tywin, and playing the role of
a monster would protect him, like armour.
But it doesn’t work.
Tyrion says he’s been “on trial for being
a dwarf” all his life.
And it’s true that people are horribly prejudiced
against him for the way he looks.
But it’s also true that Tyrion’s villainous
behaviour – his threats manipulation and
lies – are part of why people treat him
like a villain.
Finally, Shae testifies against Tyrion, after
being bribed and pressured by Cersei.
Shae says Tyrion is guilty, and humiliates
him by talking about their sex life.
This betrayal breaks Tyrion, and all his hatred
pours out.
He says he wants to poison everyone, that
he wishes he was the monster they think he
is.
Tyrion demands trial by combat, but the Mountain
kills Oberyn, so Tywin condemns his son to
death for a crime he didn’t commit.
Before his execution, Tyrion is saved by Jaime.
And this is the moment when Tyrion in the
show and Tyrion in the books go in completely
different directions.
Cause in the show, Tyrion thanks Jaime, and
they hug lovingly, then Tyrion leaves.
But in the books, Jaime
makes a terrible revelation.
After Tyrion married Tysha, Jaime had told
him that Tysha was a whore – that Jaime
paid her to be with Tyrion, and she didn’t
really love him.
But now Jaime reveals that that was a lie
that Tywin made him tell.
Jaime didn’t pay Tysha, she was just a random
peasant girl who really did love Tyrion.
All these years, Tyrion thought that no woman
would ever love him.
But now he finds out that his wife, who was
gang-raped by Tywin’s men, and by Tyrion,
was the only woman who ever loved him.
Tyrion is devastated, and furious that Jaime
kept to this lie.
It feels like the ultimate betrayal from the
one person Tyrion thought he could trust.
All Tyrion’s pain becomes rage, and he swears
to get revenge on his family, to punish the
world by becoming the villain they think he
is – he says “I am the monster they all
say I am”.
Just to hurt Jaime, he says he did kill Joffrey,
and tells him that Cersei’s been cheating
on him.
So Tyrion leaves Jaime not as a loving brother,
but as his enemy, a monster wanting revenge.
And it’s because of the revelation about
Tysha that Tyrion goes after Tywin.
And in Tywin’s bed, Tyrion finds Shae.
Tywin had always criticised Tyrion for having
sex with “whores”.
He says it’s a weakness, and a shame on
their family.
After Tywin’s wife died, he supposedly never
touched a woman – he “had no use for whores”.
Tywin acted like he had no lust, no emotions,
just cold rationality.
But now Tyrion sees that’s a lie.
Tywin does have sex, just like Tyrion.
And it’s not just Shae.
In Book 2, Tyrion uses a secret tunnel that
runs into a brothel.
Varys says that this tunnel was built for
a Hand of the King so he could visit the brothel
secretly.
And inside the brothel is a “red and yellow”
window, and “a globe of gilded metal and
scarlet glass” – those are Lannister colours,
red and gold.
And Tywin Lannister was Hand of the King.
So it was probably Tywin who built this tunnel
to visit the brothel on the regular.
Tywin even lets Shae wear his jewellery, just
like his father’s mistress wore his mother’s
jewellery.
So there are some deep dark complicated feelings
about sex and family and shame happening in
Tywin.
But the point is that Tyrion discovers that
Tywin is a massive hypocrite who does have
sex with “whores” just like he does.
In the show, when Tyrion finds Shae, Shae
grabs a knife, and they struggle, before Tyrion
kills her.
Then he cries, and apologises to her corpse.
The show tries to make the scene feel tragic,
almost sympathetic to Tyrion.
But in the books, it’s cold-blooded murder.
Shae doesn’t grab a knife.
Shae cries, and says she didn’t want to
betray Tyrion, that Cersei made her, and Tywin
scares her.
But Tyrion is angry at her betrayal, so he
strangles her to death without mercy.
Compared to the show, this is a much more
brutal, evil murder – author George Martin
calls it his “blackest deed”, “the great
crime of his soul”.
Then Tyrion gets a crossbow and finds his
noble father on the toilet.
He asks Tywin what happened to Tysha – where
did she go after the gang-rape?
Tywin doesn’t know and doesn’t care, he
says Tysha went “Wherever whores go”.
So Tyrion shoots his father.
Tywin says Tyrion is “no son of mine”,
but Tyrion says “I’m you writ small”
– meaning ‘I’m just like you’.
Cause Tywin hates Tyrion for being devious,
spiteful, and lustful.
But it turns out, Tywin is just as devious
spiteful and lustful as Tyrion.
Tywin is devious when he plots the Red Wedding.
He was spiteful when he killed Elia Martell,
and the Reynes and Castameres.
And he’s so goddamn lustful that he roots
his son’s girlfriend and builds a secret
personal sex tunnel to a brothel.
Tywin and Tyrion have the same insecurities
about being laughed at and feeling weak and
ashamed.
Tywin tries to hide his feelings behind the
image of a noble rational golden lion, someone
who’s above the petty shameful behaviour
of his dwarf son.
But it’s a lie.
It’s all bullshit, and that’s why Tywin
dies shitting himself on the toilet.
Tywin “did not, in the end, shit gold”.
Because he’s not a golden lion.
He is a deeply flawed man full of shame and
spite and lust, just like his son Tyrion.
In Book 3, Tyrion tries be loved by his family
and Shae and Sansa, but he is betrayed and
condemned by everyone close to him.
In Book 5, Tyrion goes east, drinking his
way across the sea.
He is consumed with self-loathing, anger,
and despair – he’s lost everything.
He no longer dreams of love or justice – all
he has left is hatred.
He wants to kill Jaime and Cersei, and bring
war to Westeros, he wants to punish the world
for rejecting him.
And he especially hates women.
Tyrion threatens a slave, saying he’ll have
sex with her and murder her, just for the
pleasure of making her afraid.
Tyrion’s in a very dark place, and he reacts
to his trauma and pain by hurting others and
himself.
In Pentos, Tyrion meets Illyrio, who’s working
with Varys to help Daenerys conquer Westeros.
He convinces Tyrion to join Daenerys, so that
Tyrion can get revenge on the Lannisters,
and take Casterly Rock for himself.
So Tyrion travels with a group of Illyrio’s
allies, led by this guy Griff, and this kid
Young Griff.
There’s also a septa, and a scholar, and
a knight.
And Tyrion figures out that Griff and his
crew are not who they seem.
Griff is actually Jon Connington, who was
once a lord in Westeros.
And Young Griff is actually supposedly Aegon
Targaryen, the son of Prince Rhaegar and Elia
Martell who everyone thought was dead.
Griff and Illyrio and Varys have raised Aegon
to be King – they hope to marry him to Daenerys
so they can conquer and rule Westeros together.
So they travel downriver and see some wondrous
sights – there’s a giant turtle, a naked
nun, and a strange shape in the fog that may
or may not be a dragon.
In the Sorrows, they see the ancient ruins
of the Bridge of Dream and the Palace of Love,
just like Tyrion’s dreams and loves are
now ruined – which is one of George Martin’s
less.. subtle metaphors.
The Sorrows are a strange and spooky place,
said to be ruled by a dark, mystical figure
called the Shrouded Lord.
Their boat inexplicably magically goes through
the same place twice(?!), and then they’re
attacked by stone men – people infected
with greyscale.
Tyrion saves Aegon, Jon Connington saves Tyrion,
and JonCon gets infected with greyscale, but
keeps it a secret – in the TV show, Jorah
gets greyscale, but in the books it’s JonCon.
And the disease makes JonCon desperate to
make Aegon King of Westeros ASAP – because
JonCon was in love with Aegon’s father,
Prince Rhaegar.
He feels guilty for failing Rhaegar, and wants
to redeem himself by getting Aegon on the
Throne.
He and his crew have spent years training
and protecting Aegon in secret, and now it’s
almost time to reveal him
and claim his birthright.
But Tyrion.. really doesn’t give a fuck
about JonCon and Aegon’s quest.
He makes fun of Aegon’s story as a perfect
handsome fantasy prince, and he undermines
their noble heroism with his sarcasm and cynicism
and hate.
It’s almost.. meta how Tyrion mocks the
fantasy tropes of the story that he’s in,
like Rick Sanchez being so
depressed and disillusioned
and drunk that he breaks the fourth wall a
little.
Tyrion even dresses in motley like a jester
– a villainous fool who makes fun of the
world like an edgy Westerosi Joker.
Tyrion hates JonCon because he reminds him
of Tywin.
And Aegon is an annoying hot-headed teenager.
So Tyrion mischievously messes with their
plans.
Over a game of cyvasse, which is the Game
of Thrones version of chess, Tyrion manipulates
Aegon, and convinces him to change his plan.
Instead of going east and joining forces with
Daenerys, he tells Aegon to go west and attack
Westeros by himself.
And since Aegon is young and rash, and JonCon
is impatient with his greyscale, the madlads
actually do it.
They abandon the plan, and attack Westeros
without Daenerys.
Tyrion doesn’t actually think this a good
idea – he only suggests it to mess with
them, and create chaos.
But this decision could have huge consequences.
Like, if Aegon takes the Throne himself, he
and Daenerys could become enemies instead
of allies.
There are hints that Aegon is not really a
Targaryen, he’s actually a Blackfyre.
And Daenerys is warned of a “mummer’s
dragon” or false dragon.
There are hints of a war between them, a “dance
of the dragons” that will cause death and
destruction across Westeros.
So Tyrion’s trolling might cause a terrible
war.
And he doesn’t care.
He laughs when he finds out.
In his anger and nihilism, Tyrion wants to
see the world burn.
Tyrion is haunted by memories of Tywin, Shae,
and Tysha.
Since Tysha was the one woman who truly loved
him, he wants to find her again.
He imagines them living together in their
cottage like they did when they were young
and happy.
It’s not a realistic dream, but that distant
memory is all he’s got.
Tywin said that Tysha went “Wherever whores
go”.
So Tyrion repeatedly asks “Where do whores
go?”.
Thinking of Tysha, he visits a brothel.
And he has sex with a slave prostitute who
has dead eyes and a scarred back.
Tyrion feels wretched, full of shame and guilt
and self-hatred.
He drinks til he pukes, tells the slave to
kill him, and then has sex with her again,
even though she clearly doesn’t want to
– he rapes her.
But in the TV show version of the scene, Tyrion
is charming and nice.
A slave offers him free sex, but Tyrion declines
because he’s so sad, in like a noble kind
of way.
The show whitewashes Tyrion.
It takes out the bad stuff he does and makes
him into a generic good guy who doesn’t
change as a character.
But the books go deep into Tyrion’s emotional
devastation, and he does terrible things.
Tyrion is captured by Jorah, who wants to
give him to Daenerys to get back in her favour.
And they go to Volantis, an ancient slave
city in a state of political unrest.
Cause the rulers of Volantis plan to attack
Daenerys because Daenerys is fighting against
slavery.
But the slaves of Volantis see Daenerys as
a beacon of freedom.
And the red priests preach that Daenerys is
the prophesied saviour Azor Ahai.
A woman called the widow of the waterfront
tells Tyrion that the slaves are waiting for
Daenerys to come and free them.
Tyrion agrees go help Daenerys – but not
for heroic reasons.
He says he’ll bring Daenerys his “hate”,
and the only reward he asks is to be allowed
to rape and kill his sister Cersei.
Tyrion embraces the role of monstrous villain.
Over in Braavos, Arya’s in a play where
the Tyrion character says “As I cannot be
the hero, let me be the monster, and lesson
them in fear in place of love”.
Then, Tyrion is attacked by a dwarf girl called
Penny.
Penny was one of the performers back at Joffrey’s
wedding.
But when Tyrion escaped Westeros, Cersei put
a bounty on Tyrion’s head.
So a bunch of idiot bounty hunters have killed
innocent dwarfs, thinking they might be Tyrion.
Penny’s brother Oppo was one of those killed,
and in her grief and anger, Penny blames Tyrion.
Tyrion takes pity on Penny, and brings her
with them as they sail east.
Eventually, Tyrion and Penny reconcile, and
become friends.
They’ve got a lot in common.
They’re both dwarfs who have lost their
families and their ways of life.
They’re both dealing with grief, anger,
and suicidal thoughts.
But unlike Tyrion, Penny moves past her anger.
She forgives Tyrion for her brother’s death.
And instead of wallowing in hatred and despair
like Tyrion, Penny is optimistic, with hopes
and dreams for the future.
Penny tells Tyrion to stop his self-destructive
behaviour.
Like, Tyrion makes fun of Jorah until Jorah
hits Tyrion.
And Penny tells him he’s gotta stop provoking
people or he’ll get himself killed.
It used to be that Tyrion could say what he
liked, cause he was a rich and powerful nobleman.
But now as an exile, he’s no one, so when
he talks shit he gets hit.
Tyrion has always felt sorry for himself,
but he was very lucky to be born into a rich
noble family.
He’s been protected by his privilege all
his life.
But Penny is a common person as well as dwarf,
and she’s learned the hard way how to survive.
Tyrion hates being laughed at, but Penny says
making people laugh can be a good thing.
In fact, if Tyrion had ridden her pig at Joffrey’s
wedding like Joffrey asked, instead of insulting
Joffrey, Tyrion might never have been condemned,
and Penny’s brother might not have died.
No one should have to put up with humiliation.
But many of Tyrion’s problems are caused
by his pride.
When morale on their ship gets dangerously
low, Penny convinces Tyrion to perform a joust
with her, riding her pig against her dog.
So Penny challenges Tyrion’s pride, his
privilege, his self-destructive behaviour.
She shows him that he’s not the only dwarf
in the world who’s suffered.
And that it’s possible to forgive and hope.
Penny has a crush on Tyrion, and they kiss
a couple of times.
But Tyrion isn’t interested in her like
that.
The only woman he loves is his idealised memory
of Tysha.
So Tyrion has a complicated relationship with
Penny.
He’s protective of her, and kind, sometimes,
but he rejects her love, and he mostly rejects
her positive, hopeful attitude.
Tyrion stays angry and proud and cynical.
And he moves closer to power.
A red priest called Moqorro has a vision of
Tyrion with dragons – “Dragons old and
young, true and false, bright and dark”
– with Tyrion snarling in their midst, a
small man with a big shadow.
The old dragons could be Aemon or Bloodraven.
The young and true dragons could be Daenerys
and Jon Snow who is probably secretly a Targaryen.
And the false, dark dragon could be Aegon
– cause he might actually be a Blackfyre
not a Targaryen.
And through these dragons, Tyrion will have
a big impact on the story.
In Book 1, Tyrion cast a shadow as “tall
as a king”.
Aemon said Tyrion “is a giant come among
us, here at the end of the world”.
So there’s lots of foreshadowing that Tyrion
will play a big role in the endgame of the
story.
Their ship is damaged in a storm, Moqorro
floats off to Victarion, and Tyrion Penny
and Jorah are captured by slavers outside
Meereen – the city is under siege by the
slavers of Yunkai while Daenerys tries to
negotiate peace.
Tyrion, Penny and Jorah are bought as slaves
by a Yunkishman called Yezzan zo Qaggaz, or
the Yellow Whale.
Yezzan is enormously rich and enormously fat,
and he keeps a grotesquery of slaves with
unusual bodies, watched over by his cruel
overseer, Nurse.
Tyrion has gone from a proud powerful ruler
in Westeros to a powerless humiliated slave.
Inside Meereen, Daenerys tries to make peace
with the slavers by marrying Hizdahr, and
opening the fighting pits.
Tyrion and Penny are made to perform for the
crowds – so the first time Tyrion and Daenerys
see each other, Tyrion is riding a pig.
Though she doesn’t know he’s Tyrion, and
they still haven’t met.
Cause Drogon crashes the party, Daenerys flies
off, and Yunkai prepares to attack Meereen.
A disease called the bloody flux breaks out,
and Yezzan gets sick.
Yezzan was dying already from an exotic disease
he got in Sothoryos.
So pretty soon he’s squirting his guts out,
and Tyrion takes the opportunity to escape.
On the way out, Tyrion kills Nurse with some
poison mushrooms – and says “A Lannister
always pays his debts”.
So after all the crazy stuff that happens
in this book, Tyrion is still a Lannister.
He’s still proud, spiteful, and murderous,
like his father.
The main way that Tyrion has changed since
the start of Book 5 is that he’s less depressed
now, he doesn’t want to die any more.
He originally considered using these poisoned
mushrooms to kill himself in Pentos, but now
he chooses to live, and get revenge.
Tyrion goes to a mercenary captain called
Brown Ben Plumm, commander of the Second Sons.
Tyrion convinces him to let him and Penny
and Jorah join his company to escape slavery.
And in return, Tyrion promises Ben money and
a lordship when Tyrion gets power back in
Westeros.
So Tyrion Penny and Jorah escape slavery,
but now they’re stuck in the middle of a
battle between the slavers and Daenerys’
forces.
Daenerys herself is still missing in the Dothraki
Sea.
So Barristan commands her army, alongside
Grey Worm and the Unsullied, some sellswords,
and freed slaves.
Ben Plumm and the Second Sons are on the side
of the slavers, but Tyrion hopes to convince
them to join Daenerys instead.
So Tyrion’s back in the game of thrones,
playing politics, being a Lannister again.
And he is as ruthless as ever – he compares
himself to Tywin, and thinks about poisoning
wells.
Tyrion wants to join Daenerys but not because
he.. believes in her or anything.
He just thinks that she’s his best hope
of bringing fire and sword to Westeros.
So in Book 5, Tyrion loses everything, and
falls deep into despair and hate.
But now, he’s returning to the game of thrones.
When he gets power, will he use it for violence
and vengeance like Tywin would?
Or will he find forgiveness and hope like
Penny?
Author George Martin has released sample
chapters of the upcoming next book, The Winds
of Winter.
In the opening chapters, Tyrion convinces
Ben Plumm and his men to switch sides and
join Daenerys.
Another sellsword company called the Windblown
also join Daenerys.
Victarion Greyjoy and Moqorro arrive with
the ironborn and attack the slavers.
The dragons Rhaegal and Viserion are loose.
And Ser Barristan rides into battle.
So it looks like Daenerys’ forces will defeat
the slavers, leaving a very strange bunch
of characters in charge of Meereen.
Barristan is Daenerys’ closest ally, so
Tyrion will want to win his trust – though
Tyrion suspects that Barristan will hate him
for being a villainous kinslayer.
Victarion wants to marry Daenerys and steal
her dragons, which probably won’t end well
for him.
But if he survives the battle, we could get
some fun dialogue with Tyrion making fun of
Victarion “dumb as a stump” Greyjoy.
Moqorro could teach Tyrion more about magic
and prophecy.
Marwyn the Mage should arrive sometime, and
he’s also into magic and books.
Ben Plumm and the Tattered Prince will want
battle and plunder, Jorah wants to get out
of the friendzone with Daenerys, though he’s
picked up an unfortunate face tattoo recently.
Daario is still around, and he wants Daenerys.
And Strong Belwas wants.. liver and onions.
It’s a colourful collection of characters,
and a great opportunity for Tyrion to play
politics, crack jokes, rule Meereen, and set
himself up as an advisor to Daenerys when
she returns.
Daenerys won’t trust Tyrion right away.
Cause Tyrion is a Lannister, condemned as
treacherous kingslayer.
But Tyrion is very good at convincing people
to make alliances.
And Tyrion has lots of useful information
that Daenerys needs.
Daenerys has never been to mainland Westeros.
She doesn’t know her enemies.
But Tyrion intimately knows Cersei, Jaime,
King Tommen, and other lords.
Tyrion knows the defences of King’s Landing
and Casterly Rock.
And Tyrion is the only person in Meereen who
knows about Aegon and JonCon.
Tyrion can tell her that Aegon is on his way
to take her Throne, which could convince Daenerys
to get to Westeros ASAP.
Tyrion could manipulate Daenerys and tell
her that that Aegon is her enemy, to encourage
conflict and chaos.
So, like in the show, Tyrion will probably
become Daenerys’ advisor or Hand of the
Queen.
But his advice to Daenerys may be very different
to the show.
In the show, Tyrion tells Daenerys to be merciful
to the slavers, so instead of killing them
all, they just kill some and give the rest
a stern talking to.
But book Tyrion, in his anger and hate, won’t
want mercy for the people who just enslaved
him – he’ll want revenge.
Book Daenerys also wants violence.
All through Book 5, she tries to rule Meereen
peacefully – making compromises, marrying
Hizdahr, chaining her dragons.
But peace fails, so she flies off on her dragon,
and she has visions reminding her that she
is “the blood of the dragon”, that Meereen
is not her home, that the Targaryen words
are “Fire and Blood”.
Daenerys is done with peace, she’s set to
burn her enemies.
And Daenerys once said that if Yunkai attacks
her, she will raze their city to the ground.
So Daenerys and Tyrion’s first act together
won’t be this half-assed compromise.
It might be to destroy Yunkai.
George Martin said Daenerys has “embraced
her heritage as a Targaryen”, and she and
Tyrion are “coming home”.
But it’s a long way from Meereen to Westeros.
And they have unfinished business in Essos.
The red priests and the widow of the waterfront
want Daenerys to free the slaves of Volantis.
Which might get violent – a priest prophesies
that Volantis will burn.
And conveniently, the ruling slavers of Volantis
live within the Black Walls in the heart of
the city – making them a convenient target
for Daenerys to roast them all with dragonfire.
Moqorro may convince Daenerys of her destiny
to be “a sword of fire that will cleanse
the world”, pushing her further towards
violence.
Daenerys also has business in Pentos.
Cause the captain of the Windblown, the Tattered
Prince, joins Daenerys on the condition that
he gets to take over Pentos.
Daenerys hasn’t agreed to this yet – at
first she says she won’t give Pentos to
Tatters, because Illyrio lives in Pentos,
and Illyrio is her trusted ally.
But Tyrion can tell Daenerys the truth – that
Illyrio has been lying and manipulating her
all along.
Illyrio really supports Aegon, and while Illyrio
was selling Daenerys to the Dothraki, he was
raising Aegon in secrecy and safety.
Tyrion could convince Daenerys to burn Illyrio
for his betrayal, and to give Pentos to the
Tattered Prince.
We don’t know what Tatters’ plans are
for Pentos, but it’s probably something
bad.
Tatters has history with Pentos, and he’s
a cruel and brutal man.
One time, Tatters cut off a guy’s foot,
then forced him to eat it, and then made him
his cook, that’s the sort of guy Tatters
is.
And Daenerys and Tyrion might give him the
city of Pentos.
So there are strong hints in the books that
Daenerys’ journey across Essos will be violent
and destructive, bringing fire and blood across
the continent.
Will Tyrion encourage this violence?
Or will he tell Daenerys to be more peaceful?
Tyrion’s peaceful, compassionate side is
represented by his relationship with Penny.
And in his latest chapters, he rejects her
optimism pretty harshly – he slaps her,
tells her to stop dreaming, and to face harsh
reality.
There are even hints that Tyrion might hurt
Penny.
Tyrion dreams of shooting Penny with a crossbow.
And there’s a weird dark moment when Penny
reminds Tyrion of Shae, and he’s overwhelmed
with rage, and Tyrion thinks about killing
Penny.
If Tyrion kills Penny, or just rejects or
loses her somehow, that could be the breaking
point that leads Tyrion to fully embrace Daenerys’
bloody conquest.
And Tyrion might develop a connection with
Daenerys’ dragons.
Tyrion has always been fascinated with dragons,
so he’s read lots of books about them.
This knowledge is considered so valuable that
JonCon makes him write down everything he
knows about dragons in case it’s useful.
So this knowledge is another way Tyrion can
help Daenerys.
Cause Daenerys doesn’t actually know much
about dragons, she has a
lot of trouble controlling
hers in the books.
They keep disobeying her, and eating children.
They didn’t come with a manual.
[She can’t Google it].
So Tyrion might help Daenerys control her
dragons, maybe even breed them, or design
dragon armour, or a dragon-riding saddle,
like the saddle he designed for Bran.
And maybe Tyrion will ride a dragon himself.
He does dream of riding a dragon and burning
his enemies.
And author George Martin has hinted that Tyrion
will fly.
Daenerys believes that her three dragons need
three riders.
Jon Snow will probably ride one, like he does
in the TV show.
He rides the green dragon, Rhaegal, who is
named after his [probable] father Rhaegar.
Daenerys rides the black dragon, Drogon.
So Tyrion could ride Viserion – Viserion
is coloured white and gold, and his blood
is “gold and red” which fits Tyrion’s
Lannister colours.
At the end of his latest preview chapter,
Tyrion dramatically picks up a white dragon
cyvasse piece, which hints at a connection
between him and the white dragon Viserion.
Usually, dragons are only ridden by Targaryens,
people with the Valyrian “blood of the dragon”.
And Tyrion isn’t a Targaryen.
Or is he?
There is a theory that Tyrion is not the son
of Tywin Lannister, he’s actually the son
of the Mad King, Aerys Targaryen.
Cause for years, Aerys was sexually interested
in Tyrion’s mother, Joanna Lannister.
It was rumoured that he took her virginity,
and that she was his mistress for a while.
At Joanna’s wedding to Tywin, Aerys joked
that he wanted to have sex with her, and he
took “liberties” at the bedding.
Aerys’ wife complained that Aerys was turning
her ladies into his “whores”, so Joanna
went back to Casterly Rock for a while.
But then, the year before Tyrion was born,
Aerys and Joanna were both at a tournament
in King’s Landing.
Aerys made comments about Joanna’s breasts,
and Tywin got so angry that he tried to resign
as Hand.
The next year, Tyrion was born.
So maybe, at this tournament, Aerys had sex
with Joanna and fathered Tyrion.
Being a Targaryen could explain Tyrion’s
pale blond hair, which looks more like the
Targaryen silvery blond than the Lannister
golden blond.
Tyrion’s green eye could be from his Lannister
mother, and his black eye could actually be
a very dark Targaryen purple.
Targaryen blood could explain why Tyrion doesn’t
catch greyscale or the bloody flux – because
Targaryens tend not to get sick.
It could explain Tyrion’s dreams of dragons,
which are common in Targaryens.
And Targaryen blood could let Tyrion ride
a dragon.
In Book 5, Daenerys’ dragons like Ben Plumm.
And Tyrion explains that this is because Ben
has some Targaryen blood in his family tree.
Maybe the reason this is mentioned in the
book is so that when Tyrion meets Daenerys’
dragons, they’ll like him too, hinting that
Tyrion also has Targaryen blood.
And then Barristan, who was Aerys’ guard
for years, could reveal that Aerys is Tyrion’s
father.
It all fits – the white dragon, the timeline,
his appearance, his dreams – Tyrion could
be a Targaryen.
But does the story really need another secret
Targaryen?
We’ve already got Jon Snow probably being
a secret Targaryen, and Young Griff being
a secret Targaryen or a Blackfyre.
Do we really need all three main characters
to be Targaryens, whose
mothers died in childbirth,
who ride dragons?
And if Tyrion is Aerys’s son, what does
that mean for his relationship with Tywin?
The whole point of their relationship is that
even though Tywin hates Tyrion, Tyrion is
just like Tywin, Tyrion is Tywin “writ small”.
Isn’t that ruined if Tyrion is actually
Aerys’ son?
You could argue that even if Aerys is Tyrion’s
biological father, Tywin is the father who
raised Tyrion, and his shitty parenting made
Tyrion who he is.
It’s like how even if Rhaegar is Jon Snow’s
biological father, Ned Stark is the father
who raised Jon, and made him the person who
he is.
And it kind of makes sense if Tywin always
suspected that Tyrion was Aerys’ son.
Like, he does say that Tyrion is not his son,
but that he just cannot prove that Tyrion
isn’t his.
Cause there is no proof whether Tyrion is
a Targaryen.
Only hints.
And maybe that ambiguity is the point.
Maybe we’ll never know for sure.
Like, maybe Tyrion will start to develop a
connection with Viserion, but then Viserion
will be killed or taken by Euron before Tyrion
can fully explore his Targaryen side.
So maybe he’ll always question his identity
– is he a Lannister or a Targaryen?
Tywin wondered the same thing – he was never
quite sure if Tyrion was his son, he didn’t
want to believe Tyrion was his.
Because Tyrion was a reflection of everything
Tywin hated about himself.
It’s because Tyrion is so much like Tywin
that Tywin denied Tyrion was his, and preferred
to believe he was Aerys’ instead.
But Tyrion, unlike Tywin, could face the truth
– that it doesn’t matter whether Aerys
is his biological father.
Tyrion was raised as a Lannister, his personality
and values were shaped by Tywin, so for better
or worse, no matter what’s in his blood,
“Tyrion is Tywin’s son”.
And besides, George Martin has hinted that
the third dragonrider doesn’t necessarily
need to be a Targaryen, so maybe Tyrion could
ride a dragon either way.
The other thing Tyrion needs to resolve are
his feelings about Tysha – his pain and
his longing for his lost love.
Will he ever find “where whores go”?
George Martin has said that we will find out
where whores go.
So… where?
In Braavos, Arya meets a sex worker called
the Sailor’s Wife.
Before she has sex with men, she always marries
them in a fun temporary ceremony with a drunken
priest – like how Tysha married Tyrion in
a fun ceremony with a drunken priest.
The Sailor’s Wife likes singing, like how
Tysha used to sing for Tyrion.
And she’s a “whore”, just like Tysha
was supposedly a “whore”.
The Sailor’s Wife is a fun, and kind person,
though there’s something sad about her too.
She often prays for her first husband, her
true love, to come back to her.
Maybe that husband was Tyrion, and the Sailor’s
Wife is Tysha.
She could’ve fled from Westeros, and set
herself up in Braavos.
And thing is, the Sailor’s Wife has a blonde
daughter called Lanna.
Lanna is fourteen years old, and Tysha and
Tyrion were married either fourteen or fifteen
years ago.
So the timeline fits – Lanna could be Tyrion
Lannister’s daughter with Tysha.
There are problems with this theory – like,
the Sailor’s Wife says her husband was..
a sailor.
And Tyrion’s not a sailor – so maybe her
husband was actually Tyrion’s uncle Gerion.
But the sailor thing could just be a lie she
tells to protect herself.
The other problem is that a fortune-teller
says that the Sailor’s Wife’s husband
is dead, and if he comes back to her, it will
be as a corpse.
Tyrion isn’t literally dead.
But he does think of himself
as being metaphorically
dead, having died in King’s Landing and
become a ghost.
So if The Sailor’s Wife is Tysha, maybe
he will come back to her, in Braavos.
Daenerys and Tyrion could stop there on the
way west – maybe Daenerys could borrow money
from the Iron Bank, or fight the Faceless
Men or something.
But Tyrion and Tysha’s reunion may not be
a happy one.
Because Tyrion and Tysha aren’t the innocent
teenagers they remember each other as.
Tyrion has become a “corpse” – a hateful
murderous version of the boy he used to be,
and Tysha has.. ironically become a “whore”,
which is what Tyrion always feared she was.
If a reunion with Tysha goes badly, and they
don’t meet each others’ impossible idealised
standards, that could push Tyrion into an
even darker more destructive place – right
as he arrives back at Westeros.
So in the next book, Daenerys will carve a
bloody path across Essos, with Tyrion by her
side.
Tyrion might ride a dragon, he might reunite
with Tysha, and he might lose or kill Penny.
Winds has the potential to be Tyrion’s darkest
book, where he fully embraces fire and blood.
At the end of the TV show, Daenerys
burns King’s Landing, killing thousands
of innocent people out of anger and frustration.
And a lot of people complained that this terrible
dark turn happened too suddenly.
There wasn’t enough buildup and exploration
of why Daenerys would do something so evil.
In the books, her journey across Essos could
be that gradual buildup of destruction.
Her allies and advisors in the books will
be violent fiery people like Tatters and Ben
and Moqorro, the ironborn and Dothraki.. and
Tyrion, the devil on her shoulder, urging
her to burn Westeros for his revenge.
The situation in King’s Landing will be
different.
It might be Aegon, not Cersei, who has the
Throne, possibly in alliance with Dorne, the
Reach and the Faith.
And Aegon may be popular with the common people
– there’s a vision of the mummer’s dragon
“amidst a cheering crowd”.
If the common people support Aegon over Daenerys,
Daenerys may see the people as her enemies.
Jon Connington could be there, and interestingly,
JonCon has a traumatic backstory involving
bells, which might be the reason for the bells
that ring in the show before Daenerys burns
the city.
There also could be wildfire in the mix.
Cersei and Jaime might be there, perhaps as
prisoners of Aegon.
And the spark behind the fire could be Tyrion.
Cause King’s Landing is where Tyrion was
betrayed by Tywin, Cersei, Jaime, and Shae.
It’s the city he fought to save before its
people rejected and condemned him.
He said he wished he had enough poison to
kill them all, and ever since he’s wanted
revenge, to pay his debts.
During Robert’s Rebellion, Tywin brutally
sacked King’s Landing, killing men women
and children.
And part of the reason why he did this so
savagely was probably to get revenge on King
Aerys and everyone else
who mocked and disrespected
him when he was Hand of the King.
Now Tyrion is set to repeat history, and to
attack that same city because of how he was
treated when he was Hand of the King.
Tyrion will repeat the sins of his father.
In the show, Tyrion tells Daenerys not to
burn King’s Landing, but in the books, he
could encourage or manipulate her into doing
it, by turning her against Aegon and the common
people, or by not telling her about the dangerous
wildfire, or even by starting the fire on
a dragon of his own.
However it happens, the burning King’s Landing
would be the ultimate expression of Tyrion’s
hate and pain, especially if it kills Jaime
and Cersei.
But revenge won’t make Tyrion happy in the
end.
In Book 5, he has a dream where he fights
a battle with dragons overhead.
He kills Tywin, and he kills Jaime, but then
Tyrion realises he’s crying.
As Ellaria says, revenge doesn’t fix anything.
It doesn’t bring back what you’ve lost.
A skull can’t make you happy.
In the show, Tyrion walks through the ashes
of King’s Landing, and cries over the bodies
of Jaime and Cersei.
The tragedy in the show is that Tyrion failed
to protect his family.
But in the books, the tragedy could be that
he killed his family, and only realised it
was a mistake when it was too late.
In the show, Bran makes Tyrion Hand of the
King, and says he’ll work to fix his “terrible
mistakes”.
But Tyrion’s terrible mistake in the TV
show was believing in Daenerys, who turned
evil despite his good intentions.
It could be so much more tragic in the books
if Tyrion’s “mistake” is encouraging
Daenerys’ violence, choosing hate and revenge.
So will Tyrion end the series as a villain,
like Tywin?
Or could he redeem himself?
In the show, the white walkers are defeated,
then King’s Landing burns.
But in the books, it might be the other way
around – because Jon killing Daenerys makes
more sense in the context of the white walkers,
because of the Azor Ahai story – so maybe
after Tyrion and Daenerys burn King’s Landing,
Tyrion will help defeat the white walkers.
He could finally realise that saving the world
is more important than politics and revenge.
The Night’s Watch were right, this is what
he should have been doing all along.
When Tyrion stood on the Wall in Book 1, he
felt something, he sensed that the white walkers
were the true enemy.
He could help fight them by riding a dragon
maybe, or just help politically, by building
alliances with the Starks.
Tyrion and Jon still think of each other as
friends, and Tyrion has relationships with
Bran and his wife Sansa.
So maybe Tyrion will team up with the Starks
and redeem himself by saving the world from
the white walkers.
Or maybe that’s too much of a happy ending.
Maybe Tyrion deserves punishment.
Characters talk about cutting out Tyrion’s
tongue eight times in the books.
Because Tyrion constantly annoys people with
his jokes and insults, and his words cause
so much trouble.
Removing someone’s tongue is a common punishment
in Westeros.
Euron Greyjoy often cuts out peoples’ tongues,
and he’s becoming a major bad guy in the
books.
He might take Tyrion’s dragon Viserion,
before taking Tyrion’s tongue.
Cersei is another possibility – she hates
Tyrion, and she’s been talking a lot about
cutting out tongues lately.
Tyrion losing his tongue would fit a pattern
with his siblings – cause each of the Lannisters
lose the part of themselves that give them
power and pride.
Jaime loses his hand that made him a great
warrior.
Cersei loses her image as a proud beautiful
queen in her walk of shame.
And Tyrion’s power and pride is in his sharp
witty tongue, so if he loses his tongue, all
three Lannisters will have lost their most
important part.
When Jaime loses his hand, and Bran breaks
his back, and Arya loses her sight, these
are challenges that force the characters to
grow and redefine themselves.
But Tyrion has kind of already had his downfall
– he’s already lost everything.
So losing his tongue might not be about growing
his character.
It could be more of a brutal final tragedy
at the end of his story, as a punishment for
all his crimes.
If Tyrion’s words and lies convince Daenerys
to burn King’s Landing, maybe King Bran
will take Tyrion’s tongue so his words can’t
do evil again.
He could live out his days as a quiet lion
at Casterly Rock, or as a mute maester at
the Citadel, or with the Night’s Watch.
Tyrion remembers that Jeor Mormont said they
need men like Tyrion in the Watch.
Tyrion remembers that the Watch welcomes outcasts
and misfits no matter their past crimes – which
is perfect for a criminal outcast like Tyrion.
Maybe with the brotherhood of the Watch, Tyrion
will finally find the family and acceptance
he’s always wanted.
Sam says that someone really needs to sort
through the books in the Castle Black library,
which’ll take years of work.
But Sam will be busy being Grand Maester.
So maybe Tyrion could sort out the Night’s
Watch’s books.
Tyrion’s first chapter begins with him reading
a book – that was always his comfort and
his escape.
So maybe the series will end with Tyrion reading
a book – quietly.
So is Tyrion Lannister a villain?
From the beginning, Tyrion felt unloved and
rejected.
So he used political power to try to earn
some respect.
But then he was betrayed and condemned by
the people closest to him.
So Tyrion falls deep into despair and hate,
and dreams of revenge.
In the next book, he may embrace fire and
blood.
He might spark the burning of King’s Landing.
But he might also help save the world from
the white walkers.
Tyrion is villainous – he’s a hateful,
ruthless murderer, like his father.
But he is also heroic – he is sometimes
kind, protective and brave.
George Martin did once call Tyrion a villain,
but he more often calls Tyrion morally grey.
Martin writes about the human heart in conflict
with itself.
And no one’s heart is more conflicted than
Tyrion’s.
There’s love and hate, good and evil inside
him.
And to be human is to look for the light.
If you want the real story of Game of Thrones,
you’ve got to check out the books – the
main series, and the prequel stories, and
the history books.
You can get any one of these on audiobook
for free right now, at audible.com/asx.
Sign up for a Premium Plus trial membership,
and you get an audiobook to keep, even if
you cancel the trial.
You could get Dune, or Wheel of Time, or The
Expanse.
Membership also includes unlimited access
to thousands of audiobooks and shows in the
Audible Plus Catalog.
Sign up at audible.com/asx, or text asx to
500-500.
There’s still more to say about Tyrion,
so there’ll be a Q&A livestream on this
channel in a few days at the link below.
Also Alt Schwift X has released a rap about
Tyrion for some reason, so you can check that
out, but.. don’t encourage him.
Thanks to the artists and fan essayists linked
below.
And thanks to the Patrons, including Qiara
& Karth, Eli Lidkea, JValk, Michelle, Dan
Marks, Mallie Brossett, Lady Dyanna, Kalle
Havumäki, and Carla Lindeman.
Cheers.